but here's one person who doesn't
necessarily care if Donald Trump is
innocent guilty or what the heck happens
to him and that person happens to be his
spouse former first lady Melania Trump
after several weeks of trying to just
ignore all of the legal problems that
her husband is facing Melania Trump
finally came out this week and released
a statement attacking the media for all
of their reporting on her allegedly not
giving one single care about what is
happening to her husband
so let me read you this statement
because
I don't think this statement really says
what Melania had wanted it to say
here it is
news organizations have made assumptions
about the former first ladies stance on
subjects that are personal professional
and political over the past few weeks in
these articles unnamed sources are cited
to bolster the author's claims
we ask readers to exercise caution and
good judgment when determining whether
or not stories concerning the former
first lady are accurate particularly
when they fail to cite Mrs Trump as a
source of information
so
you're not actually saying that they're
not accurate you're just saying hey
folks you may want to think for a minute
and and then decide if it's accurate
but you you're you're not denying the
stories by telling people make up your
own mind like that's that's what they
were already doing you don't have to
tell people to make up their own minds
because they've already made up their
own minds
and these reports citing Anonymous
sources sure I know how much that drives
you all crazy down there in Republican
land but they're talking to sources
close to you they're talking to people
who know you people who work for you
people who have been around you for
years
and they don't want to be named because
they probably don't want to lose their
jobs kind of seems like a pretty easy
Gig if you ask me probably pays pretty
well and yeah you don't want to lose it
but you also want the public to know
what's really happening
so what we know from Melania Trump based
on recent reporting I mean we've had
reports you know Rolling Stone Vanity
Fair uh you know pretty much all major
Outlets The Daily Beast Melania Trump as
we all know did not attend her husband's
victory speech after his indictment and
arraignment last Tuesday so she didn't
show up for that
previous reports before that even
happened said Melania Trump wants
nothing to do with her husband's legal
problems
she's going about living her life she
lives in a separate Wing at Mar-A-Lago
they do not share living quarters so
they're not even sleeping in the same
bed so that's usually a pretty big
indication that there's some marital
problems there and these reports say
that Melania spends most of her days
happy with with Baron and her parents
who also live down there and they're
just going about their lives as if none
of this is even happening
good for her right I'm not going to
fault you for that
your your marriage appears based on what
we see to be falling apart you know
based on all of the you know Visual
Evidence you don't even seem to like the
guy
I honest to God can't figure out why
you're even still with him you you look
miserable all the time when you're
around him and then when there's photos
or videos of you with not Donald Trump
you seem to look happy
I mean you know it doesn't take a a
marriage counselor to understand that
you are happier when you're not with
this guy so maybe it's time to cut bait
and just say hey thanks but uh I'm out
either way it's your life you do
whatever you want but
your your little message here your your
denial of the stories which isn't
actually a denial that doesn't help your
case
it just makes it sound like hey some of
these may be true some of them may not
be who knows I don't know do you
not exactly the Stellar statement that
you thought you were making so I don't
know maybe go back to the drawing board
maybe come up with a better statement
maybe deny the stories or hell maybe
confirm them put it all to rest the
focus is on your husband anyway nobody
wants to be talking about Melania she's
not doing anything like I said she's
living her life and seemingly happy
but don't go out there and and poke the
media and accuse them of things when
you're not even denying the things that
they're reporting
that's not exactly honest either one of
our sponsors is Helix sleep I have been
sleeping on a helix mattress at home for
years now I couldn't be more happy with
it I recommend it to everybody the other
day even though she's not allowed in the
big bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you were supporting
good jobs Helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 percent off plus two
free pillows what other mattress company
is going to give you 20 off go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is down
below